le champ dévasté dégage encore une odeur
de brûlé 30 hectares d'orge partis en
fumée de l'orge destiné aux brasseries
ou à l'alimentation des animaux
la chaleur un sol sec un peu de vent il
suffit d'une étincelle durant la moisson
c'est des cailloux avec le frottement de
la tôle de fonds de lacs de comment la
coupe cas certainement mines une
étincelle quoi je me suis aperçu comme
je vous le disais quand j'ai fait
demi-tour dans le champ quoi et ça a
pris très vite
c'est une thèse grand v avec y avait un
peu de vent donc ça a pris dans les
récoltes et lassé des flammes de m
pendant plusieurs heures une
cinquantaine de sapeurs pompiers ont
tenté de maîtriser le feu proche des
habitations
oh là là puis j'ai vu toutes les flammes
au niveau des chenils fait ça c'est
parti comme ça ça fait peur le feu juste
avant que les pompiers arrivent et un
bénévole qui travaillaient déjà qui
était pompier avant qui est venu le hall
avec des pelles pour tasser pour
éteindre le feu quoi dans le loiret 150
hectares de récoltes ont brûlé ces
derniers jours
depuis jeudi les pompiers multiplient
les sorties particulièrement dans l'est
du département
depuis environ un peu plus d'un mois
nous n'avons observé aucune
précipitation ou très peu la végétation
est arrivé à maturité et
la végétation très sèche donc de
nombreux départs de feu sont à déplorer
avec les fortes chaleurs annoncées
les risques sont accrus cette semaine